mm-hmm
and it's after that as well like uh you
you'll be you'll find that you're more
peaceful when you've got a guy taking
care of you like I tell women this all
the time it's not so it's not hard to
get a man who provides for you you just
have to be a woman who can appreciate
that right and you can't allow fear that
he's gonna have control you know that's
the term he's uncontrolling right he's
gonna control you you got to be able to
to know that your God got your best
interest at heart and that whatever he
does is for the best for you both and
the rest of that it's not there are guys
out here who want that it's just a lot
of women there's a level of distrust and
that that won't allow you to embrace and
just rest in your femininity right there
being somebody's mama so yeah deal with
that right what being somebody's mama no
I don't want to yeah so yeah so you
can't get 100 man
okay what you can't get 100 man
100 man like this for Friday
provider yeah I would love to you you're
gonna no you just said you wouldn't
okay maybe I misunderstood
I give you a company yes well I think
it's because earlier you said you should
have a backup plan
but like if you're if you have a guy
that's providing you don't have a backup
plan so I think he's saying like you
said you would love that but you also
said you wouldn't okay you said you
didn't want to be his mom either so
that's what I'm saying
yeah no I guess in my past relationships
I have been the mom I have you know done
a lot of things in the home and it's
hard I love moms yeah I think you guys
would have to having two different
definitions of the mom yeah maybe so
yeah maybe so I think you're thinking
off more like the nurturing no I'm
saying that's what modern women call it
uh you know Housewives
call it being a Slave yeah or a slave I
should get to my nerves I just want to
make a point as well so a lot of ladies
say that they want the man to be
providers and I think that you should
but don't underestimate women provide as
well you are providers of something so
we talked about the home and peas and
things you provide that as well
um and just like you say you don't want
to take care of a man think about think
about how this sounds like I want a man
to pay all the bills you know protect me
provide for me love me nurture me
you know what I mean so the trade-off is
to give him what he wants and sometimes
what we call being his mama is really
you just being nurturing you know what I
mean and I think women got to be okay
with nurturing their man
that's what do you guys think the
difference is between being nurturing
too like to him like do you think what
he's saying is true
I think the difference between being his
mom is like making decisions for him
telling him what to do
because maybe that was the situation you
were in like you had to make the
decision you were at the head like what
do you what do you want to do and he's
like I don't know yeah
very passive yeah I can't make a
decision to save his life yeah that's
the worst
yeah what do you think I think that
makes sense but there's a flips out to
that so a lot of a lot of times you
think guys are indecisive really they've
been raised by Mamas and so they want to
make you happy so it's what were you
where do you want to go what do you want
to do and that's their way of trying to
please you so it looks like it's
weakness but it's really I'm just trying
to please you I wonder if like you were
like do you feel like with those guys if
you're direct with them and say like I
want you to make decisions that they
would like listen or know
I think men like women that are
assertive and like know what they want
and can make that decision like yes
all right
do you like women that are assertive yes
yeah I don't like indecisive women yeah
there's no Clarity in the United States
that's the word Clarity yeah yeah I
don't have clarity
do you like a woman to tell you what to
do no you're not gonna tell me what to
do
so you don't really like
no Clarity means that you know what the
hell you want to do but you're not about
to tell me what to do uh uh so not not
necessarily depending on you for every
decision in my life but also not
controlling your life
no wait what do you repeat that I'm not
I
decisive and
depending on you
on you also not telling well I'm just
talking about in between us I need you
to have Clarity you know some a lot of
women don't know what they want to do
with who they're talking to uh oh okay
right can I have an example
for example if you get a chick's number
she doesn't know what she wants to do
with you after that
okay yeah there's a lot of texting games
I don't play games
so
just like she doesn't know if she wants
to hang like because I'm just imagining
you get a girl's number you ask her on a
date she says yes or no that's what you
would think
how does it okay how does it go well
usually I have to play with you for like
two weeks or something like that and if
I I can't win I come off Direct that's
the problem if I'm trying to play it out
that's another problem I go to Brazil
it's a complete flute
[Laughter]
can you give another example where it
happens further along in a relationship
further along
give me an example of what you want me
to give an example of well meaning like
you said that she's unsure she doesn't
know what she wants so give me an
example of like where you would see that
for the longing relationship to make you
question it has to it could be within a
month or two because I'm just maybe you
didn't see it on the front end but then
it's like uh I've had a chick that when
we first met she claimed she had just
got a relationship so she said she
didn't want us to have a relationship
for six months and then I flew her out
here and when she gets back she's like
We're exclusive now I was like no we're
not you said six months has been two and
a half and that now she wants to cut me
off I don't care
I'm thinking you asking women not to be
decisive is like asking water not to be
wet that's just like women not to be
decisive yeah like or to be decisive
like women are indecisive even if you
look at like feminine traits indecisive
this is a feminine trait is a problem
when you're indecisive where it
sabotages everything yeah I agree yeah
yeah
I can decide you know if you don't know
where you want to go out to eat that's
fine but yeah if you don't know if you
want to [ __ ] with me or not that's not
gonna that's not gonna fly I'm not
dealing with it
do you would you guys prefer a guy
that's a provider or a protector
a provider provider provider
a little bit of both a little yeah a
little bit but I think if I had to
choose
um
a protector I would pick protect I'm
like surprised you say provide like I
would be protector over everything I
think it's because I come from a family
of all men all my my cousins and you
know stuff are men and so I've always
had so much uh male uh contributions and
feeling protected from family that I'm
like man I don't I don't want that
completely with my with my partner I
feel like I have it enough with my my
family so I'd prefer I mean just in the
are the guys are the guys you typically
pick providers because it sounds like
the guys you pick typically you said you
like paid more so it sounds like no I
said we were 50 50. so as always
um my last relationship we both were
contributing
um the same financially okay why are you
laughing yeah I was laughing
why are you laughing because because
like so so how I think of it maybe
because I don't come from a family of a
lot of men but it's like
um I would much rather my man protect me
and my family my kids from danger and
then we can figure out the provide the
provision part of it and um it's more
than just financially provided you know
it's like there are other things he can
provide like his protection
um so to to to to just I feel like like
we like we use men as as wallets and
ATMs and stuff and we don't think other
things that they you know they
contribute to the relationship and then
I'm thinking of I have my kids and I'm
like like someone is breaking in and
then my husband nudging me because he's
not a protector to go downstairs and
look hell no
I'm just thinking like I feel like the
most genuine relationships are when he's
a protector because if you visit the
provider like when wouldn't you say like
you'd just be gone if the money's gone
yes yeah
You can disagree it's okay like I'm just
curious I agree
would I be gone if the money was gone
like I just feel like the girls that are
down if you're a protector like they're
down for the ups and the Downs like
through it all but if you're there
because he's a provider like I would
just think the money goes you're gone
too
I mean ideally I would want both yeah
you know but I think I think also if
he's a protector he's going to want to
protect us from being evicted and like
being on the streets like he's gonna
want to provide
what do you what do you think
like she said I really think he'll
protect you from being homeless yeah
yeah what is your experience do you
think women like prefer guys that
protect or provide if they had to pick
I would say Protect protect yeah pretty
I see provide why
um most women
typically say they have people that
protect them a lot of women can't say
that they've had a man that provides for
them and I see it differently I think a
man who's willing to go work for his
woman and take care of her that takes a
level of fierceness to to take care of
your life in another life as well maybe
you guys have kids and those those kind
of men when you work for something
you're fierce in protecting that and so
I think I think I think from what I've
seen women want providers because you're
not going to be fighting every day and
if if you if this is a fear my provision
is going to put us in a different zip
code so that this isn't a problem and if
I need to be with some security I can
pay for that as well you see what I'm
saying so I think it's the mindset when
it comes to the provider I find that the
old older women are they tend to say
provider more yeah yeah because I I
asked a couple girls on my last like
trip and they were like in their mid-30s
and they said provider because like the
world's pretty safe today yeah yeah
that's what the police are for right
that's the way it's the system that's
playing the place I'm sorry because like
so
like so when I first moved into my
apartment so
I saw I know it was like it's like kind
of in the hood like the gentrifications
you know it's on the border and like I
called the cops and they're like oh is
he still there and I was like No And the
cops gonna come but if I had a man at
the time I know he would have been there
you know so it's like yeah you said
that's what the cops are for and the
world is safe gone not for me personally
you have a gun or no no we're in Texas I
just assumed I just assumed everyone's
got one
but oh my God that's so scary did like
did
like did he try to chew again or did he
go so my apartment is brand new right
um at the time when I moved in a couple
years ago so it was like um a lot of the
apartments were empty so it was one of
the homeless man was trying to see which
one is empty and I had just moved in
like I was literally like moving my
things from the Cars I was going back
and forth and luckily I had locked the
door and as I was reaching for the
handle I saw it moved and I called the
cops in a [ __ ] they don't lock the
empty Apartments
because it was like brand new it was
still Construction
oh God I'm like are you mad I was scared
I would be I'd be terrified and then
they just never came never came that's
so mad to me they didn't want to see
who's trying to break into your room
because they're like oh is he still
there and it was like No And they were
like oh what if they came back
they want to get like security footage
or nothing
no no no no as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible